[Musique]
eh bien nous a dit un jour pourquoi nous
racontez vous pas d'histoires des
histoires drôles bien entendu car le
public aime l'histoire drôle ou
dénicheur marseillaise adore l'histoire
écossaise il goûte l'histoire corse il
raffole de l'histoire de foot voici donc
ce soir l'histoire de france autrefois
notre pays s'appelait la gaule et ses
habitants des gaulois tu leur prêtre
s'appelait des druides et les gaulois
les adorait surtout aux bleus sur viva
relais francs les freins n'avaient pas
de devises de leurs ennemis disait
volontiers le franc ne vaut pas cher
déjà le plus célèbre défendu charlemagne
fils de son père et de berthe aux grands
pieds patronne des agents de police les
croise un peu trop brouillon gallisa
première croisade
ce fut en quelque sorte le premier
voyage organisé quelques croisé célèbre
saint louis pierre l'ermite évasif
d'arts croisés d'origine germanique
ça lui aimait faire la grasse matinée le
dimanche matin c'est pour ça qu'on
disait de lui il est très pieux pierre
l'ermite surnommé ainsi à cause de ses
vêtements plein de trous n'avait pas de
cheval pour se rendre à jérusalem il fit
du croisé stop jetons à présent un coup
d'oeil sur la guerre de cent ans
oui voyons tous vu comment ça servait un
passionnant ça c'est pas de la tarte
les onglets occupait la france depuis de
longues années mais une jeune lorraine à
l'origine brûler du désir de sauver la
france
son désir se réalisent à elles brûlent
une autre femme célèbre j'en achète j'en
achète et dépensière elle devait fonder
une librairie bien connue aujourd'hui
sous le nom de librairie gallimard
et voici françois 1er françois 1er et
est très grand le principal adversaire
de france premier tech harlequins petite
anecdote bonjour monsieur qu'un vous
tous c'est ici oui j'ai une quinte
corredor j'ai gagné et pour continuer
quelques dates au hasard 15 115 marignan
15 116,15 sans cesse quand je vois pas
du tout bien premier anniversaire la
bataille de marignan qui était
christophe colomb le christophe colomb
qui habitait jeunes disaient je veux
découvrir l'amérique car âge n ya pas de
plaisir à son retour d'amérique il fonde
avec un camarade de régiment nommé
kléber
son héros ptt une fabrique des
pneumatiques qu'ils appelèrent kléber
que l'ongle ce qui fit dire à sa vieille
maman tu as des goodrich colomb du temps
bea qui lui manquaient de caractère à
vente à l'imprimerie
quels étaient les noms des six bourgeois
de calais stage aux empires bismarck
aznavour bernard buffet boussac et
bouchara qu ils devaient s'associer plus
tard avec les trois mousquetaires pour
fonder les cent mille chemises nous
sauterons henri iii ce qui ne change
rien à l'histoire
et voilà henri iv tout ça non c'est une
image henri iv vente à la poule au pot
il fait en quelque sorte le précurseur
des potages liebig
mais il fut assassiné par ravaillac qui
préfèrent le roi qu à la mort d'henri iv
son fils louis xiii étaient mineures où
on ne sait pas si c'est dans le nord au
creusot ils ne disent pas on dit que
louis xiii ta fille de sa femme écrit
sur lui après le 14 qu'à son tour d'un
petit fils tom et louis cas ce qu'il
devait il faut pas confondre marchi et
maternité je vous en prie ne confondez
pas voici donc louis xiv louis xiv
allons si je vous en prie non cet
avenant cet amour bonjour monsieur 14
l'état c'est moi oui mais à part ça
l'état c'est moi mais encore l'état
c'est moi est à ça c'est par moi c'était
une plaisanterie de l'époque a vendu 14
8-15 après louis 15 oui c'est sûr mais
le déluge local des lieux parce que
louis 15 avait dit après moi le déluge
à saint louis saez est bon mais
étourneaux n'est jamais dans le bain
nizet mara il perd facilement la tête
la révolution française ii le prouve à
force de crier vive la république les
français en panne en preuve
napoléon 1er qui mourut des suites de la
nourriture anglaise à propos de
nourriture parlons de la restauration
quelques restaurateurs célèbre louis
xviii
nous avons charles disent qu'ils
seraient sacrés à reims avec ses grandes
chaussures quelles grandes chaussures
paris en grande pompe et aux fins louis
philippe à qui nous devons la conquête
de l'algérie
la première république nous a donné
napoléon 1er la seconde nous donne
napoléon iii à qui nous devons la
guitare prussienne de soda et nous assis
sous la troisième république quelques
faisons waza passeur découvre le vaccin
contre la rage dans un moment de colère
et en 1909 blériot traverse la manche au
monsieur blériot comme vous avez maigri
mais oui tout le monde dit que je
décolle puis 14 18 40 40 45 quatrième
république 13 mai
quand huit jerry français et cinquième
république je pose waterloo et je
retiens devraient donner jeudi visent
louis xiv par henry 2 ce qui donne
charles vii
vous ajoutez deux gouttes de louis xviii
une larme d'albert lebrun vous envoyez
le tout quatre ans en angleterre et ça
vous donne quelqu'un que vous avez
compris
[Musique]